president biden triumphantly announces
america's surrender in afghanistan as
the taliban reimposed dystopian
theocracy and murder our erstwhile
allies i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the bench bureau show you sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn.com
ben well if you are worried about
everything running it directly into the
mud one of the things you might think
about doing is diversifying your
portfolio that means getting at least
some precious metals in the recent
budget proposal the white house budget
office forecast inflation for 2021 at
2.1 percent in june the actual inflation
rate was 5.4 the point inflation is here
it is coming faster than the government
was prepared for their solution is to
spend a lot more money so don't stick
your head in the sand the same way they
are instead hedge your savings against
inflation by diversifying into gold and
silver with birch gold group if you
haven't reached out to birch gold to
diversify part of your ira or 401k into
a precious metals ira go ahead and do it
today text ben to 47 47 47 get a free
information kit on protecting your
savings with gold i buy my gold from
birch gold they've got an a plus rating
with the better business bureau
countless 5 star reviews thousands of
happy customers talk to them have them
help you safeguard your retirement
savings text ben 247 47 47 today to
claim your free no obligation
information kit and to speak with the
precious metals expert on holding gold
and silver in a text sheltered account
again text my name ben to 4747 47 to get
started and protect your savings from
the predations of the central government
today alrighty so
we are watching in real time the worst
american foreign policy debacle of my
lifetime now admittedly i was born in
1984 so i do not remember the pull out
from saigon in 1975 but this is easily
the worst foreign policy debacle since
then
probably it is worse than that because
remember
at least it can be said of the viet cong
that they didn't you know
attack the empire state building in 1955
the taliban sheltered the people who
took down the world trade centers and
attacked the pentagon on 9 11 and now we
are turning the country back over to
them
and what's most incredible about this is
that our daughtering fool of a president
and he is a fool
he did this for no reason none there was
no rational reason for him to do what he
did certainly not in the way that he did
it even if you think we shouldn't be in
afghanistan which as we'll talk about i
think is a foolhardy idea but even if
you believe that there was a way to do
this that was at least somewhat
organized biden didn't do any of that
instead biden because he is an
ideological idiot decided that he would
run his ideology directly up against the
brick wall of reality now i i will say
i'm amused to see how many people
in the commentary a team shocked
seem shocked by the idiocy of joe biden
so for example politico europe has an
entire piece about how people in europe
can't believe how bad biden is at this
quote disbelief in betrayal europe
reacts to biden's afghanistan quote
unquote miscalculation the first line of
this piece reads quote until sunday
europe thought joe biden was an expert
on foreign policy
well i guess all i can take away from
that is that europe is filled with
clinical morons because who in the world
thought joe biden was an expert on
foreign policy he's not been right on a
single major foreign policy issue for
his entire career
and now that he occupies the oval office
that's a very dangerous thing see the
thing is about the presidency the
presidency has to negotiate with
congress the presidency has to work
through the supreme court the presidency
on domestic policy has at least some
checks and balances including
state-level authorities that come into
conflict with the federal government
when it comes to foreign policy the
presidency the executive branch has
nearly plenary power and that means that
if the president of the united states
decides to unilaterally undermine
american foreign policy in unique and
depressing ways he can do it
joe biden was fully committed to the
idea that he was going to pull out of
afghanistan damned be the consequences
and the consequences are here and they
are hideous you're going to see tens of
thousands of erstwhile american allies
slaughtered in the streets in
afghanistan you're going to see people
who are abandoned to the predations of
the taliban you're going to see a
geopolitical collapse around this there
are real consequences to this that are
not limited to afghanistan we'll get
into that okay so all of that said joe
biden
yesterday he gave a speech
and his speech was supposed to lay out
the rationale for this remember he was
off in camp david he had called a lid
joe biden had no plans to actually speak
to the american public until like
wednesday or thursday because after all
joe biden was eating ice cream and
watching math lock up in camp david he
couldn't be bothered all he did over the
weekend was release a photo of himself a
pathetic looking photo of himself alone
in the situation room talking via
conference call with all the generals
who had already advised him not to do
this
and then monitoring the collapse of
afghanistan in real time well finally he
flew back to washington dc
he did a little speech at the white
house and then he took like three
questions and then he left and that was
it
because here's the thing about your
caring grandfatherly empathetic old man
president he does not give one damn
about the people we made promises to he
doesn't care that americans are still
stuck in in afghanistan right now
somewhere between five and ten thousand
of them he does not care that tens of
thousands when i say tens of thousands i
mean probably at least a hundred
thousand people who are connected to the
afghan government who are allies people
who worked on intelligence with us
people who served in the afghan military
with the united states military and
their families those people are stuck
there and they will remain stuck there
and joe biden does not give a bleep for
captain humanitarian policy over here it
turns out he doesn't care it doesn't
matter one iota to him because in the
end he's just a venal corrupt old
politician that's all he is that's all
he ever was he was never
captain empathy now i've said a thousand
times that you should not look to
politicians for empathy
right if you're looking to politicians
for empathy you're looking in the wrong
place because politics shouldn't be
about empathy
politics should be about making
hard-headed decisions but that's the
thing joe biden's decision here wasn't
even hard-headed real politique it was
not a realist foreign policy decision
his decision here was very simple he was
going to abandon afghanistan come hell
or high water and hell on high water
have come
okay so he made the speech yesterday and
it was notable for its complete lack of
honesty the number of lies that joe
biden told in the speech it beggars the
imagination
the number of for varications
the self-congrat i've never seen a
president congratulate himself on a
greater failure than this
this is as though gerald ford had called
the presser
after the abandonment of saigon and then
congratulated himself for his bravery in
abandoning millions of people to the
evils of the viet cong remember
afghanistan by the way is 38 million
people live in afghanistan
hey but that's exactly what joe biden
did japan did a press conference where
he blamed every single person other than
himself everyone as we'll see he blamed
everyone for the decision that he alone
made in precipitous fashion
against the advice of his generals
against the advice of his intelligence
authorities against the advice of all
prior presidents he made this call he
owns this call but he tried to blame
everybody else and he patted himself on
the back as a man of high moral
character for having abandoned people
the united states made commitments too
we're running out of allies to betray
here
we've betrayed the kurds
we've betrayed the people of hong kong
we've done nothing for the dissidents in
iran we've done nothing for the
descendants in cuba and now we've
allowed people who we actively engaged
with people we actively encouraged to
fight back against the taliban and by
the way they did fifty thousand five
zero thousand fifty thousand afghan
military members have been killed in the
last seven years alone fighting against
the talibans when you hear all these
people saying the afghan military wasn't
willing to fight we were we were
fighting their war for them the united
states has not been in an active combat
role in afghanistan since 2014 when nato
officially stopped doing that last year
since february 20 since february 8 2020
the united states has not lost a soldier
in combat
not one
and we were losing
either low double digits or single
digits numbers of soldiers in combat in
afghanistan year on year since 2014.
meanwhile the afghan military was taking
tens of thousands of casualties so the
notion that the afghan military has been
doing nothing over the past few years is
just a lie
we'll discuss that in just a second
because again joe biden blamed the
afghan military for decisions he himself
made
but we begin at the beginning with joe
biden's pathetic muelling disgusting
speech i mean this is really one of the
most disreputable speeches i've ever
seen an american president give it is
despicable it is morally despicable it
is a despicable lie through and through
so let's start at the beginning first he
starts with an open lie he says he made
contingency plans for this bull no he
did not he'd not even come close to
making contingency contingency plans for
this here is joe biden just lying right
right out the gate here
my national security team and i have
been closely monitoring the situation on
the ground in afghanistan
and moving quickly to execute the plans
we had put in place to respond to every
constituency including and contingency
including the rapid collapse
we're seeing now
okay you had no plans for the rapid
collapse we're seeing now in fact joe
biden would later admit that by the way
what were those plans exactly i mean
let's go through what's exactly been
happening in afghanistan over the last
several days remember this
administration said that the taliban
would not take over the country period
as of july
anthony blinken said like a few weeks
ago
there would be no situation which the
taliban over the course of a weekend
took over afghanistan which is basically
what they did it took about a week like
a week and a half
from them taking over like the the third
biggest city in afghanistan so then
taking over kandahar and then taking
over kabul
i mean let's just go through this we saw
over the weekend helicopters taking off
from the roof of the u.s embassy
evacuating u.s embassy personnel
did he have a contingency plan for that
we saw afghans rushing the airport now
remember this is because the united
states decided to abandon baogram air
base to the predations of the taliban so
he had no military air base from which
to fly people out only the kabul airport
was available and the united states did
not have enough people there to defend
the kabul airport so people were just
rushing the tarmac you can see the
afghans climbing the walls attempting to
get in
okay you can i mean this video afghans i
mean this is stunning footage afghans
running along with the us air force
plane
clinging to the wings of the plane
clinging to the was that the contingency
plan mr president
those are those are human beings sitting
on the okay this one is the most
egregious of all obviously you can see
you see that dot falling right there
those two dots falling right there those
are people those are human beings
okay this entire debacle began with
human beings jumping from the twin
towers on 911 after al qaeda based in
afghanistan harbored by the taliban hit
the twin towers and now this debacle
ends with afghans falling from the
wheels of american planes those afghans
climbed into the wheels of the american
plains to try and escape the
theocratic tyranny of the taliban
by the way another story from politico
today body of dead afghan found in
landing gear of military jet leaving
kabul airport
the body of an afghan so desperate to
escape the country hours after kabul
fell to the taliban was found in the
landing gear of a c-17 transport
aircraft hours after it hastily took off
from hamid karzai international airport
according to two sources familiar with
the matter
the body in the aircraft's landing gear
has made it temporarily inoperable the
sources said
by the way some seven people were killed
at the on the tarmac because of the rush
on the tarmac
apparently the taliban are now going
house to house and killing people
and that's the fallout bill crystal
tweeted this out he's been receiving
texts from people in afghanistan by the
way i'm getting emails from people
desperately trying to get the afghan
interpreters they worked with members of
the military who are now in the united
states trying to get members of the
afghan military who they worked with
their translators people they worked
with in the military out of afghanistan
and receiving no support from the biden
administration and doing this i'm
getting emails about it
bill crystal tweeted out i just got off
the phone with somebody who recently
returned from his third tour in
afghanistan he emphasized we had a
responsibility not just to translators
but to afghan troops pilots and special
forces in particular who fought bravely
by our side
and he continued by pointing out that he
had received a text quote terrorists are
going door to door and killing pilots
and special operating forces raping
their families taking their houses two
of my friends were shot dead in kabul
meanwhile just just in case you didn't
know what the taliban are up to they've
also been painting out the images of
women if they're any images of women in
kabul they're going around with white
paints and they're painting over them to
make sure that women are never seen
again
okay that that was the contingency plan
from joe biden okay he said that right
out of the gate in this speech that was
his opening gambit was we had a
contingency plan
it's a hell of a contingency plan right
there that was just the beginning of the
lies we'll get some more in one second
first let's talk for a second about a
simple fact when you're running a
business business issues like hr they
can kill you wrongful termination suits
minimum wage requirements labor
regulations hr managers salaries aren't
cheap they're an average of 70 000 bucks
a year bambi is spelled b-a-m-e-e it was
created specifically for small business
you can get a dedicated hr manager craft
hr policy maintain your compliance all
for just 99 bucks a month with bambi you
can change hr from your biggest
liability to your biggest strength your
dedicated hr manager is available by
phone email or real-time chat from
onboarding determinations they customize
your policies to fit your business and
help you manage your employees
day-to-day all for just 99 bucks a month
they are month-to-month no hidden fees
you can cancel any time you didn't start
your business because you wanted to deal
with hr issues why not get that hr stuff
squared away like right now
as soon as you start your business go to
bambi.com right now schedule your free
hr audit that is bambi.com
shapiro spelled
b-a-m-b-e-e dot com
shapiro once more bambi.com
shapiro you can schedule a free hr audit
and take care of the issue that could
haunt you if you don't take care of it
now your hr bambi.com
shapiro right now alrighty meanwhile
joe biden continues and he talks about
he makes the case that the united states
actually accomplished its goal in
afghanistan
okay well
not really
i mean here's the thing in order for us
to accomplish our goal in afghanistan
our goal in afghanistan was pretty clear
right our goal in afghanistan was that
we were supposed to counter terrorism in
order to do that we have to continue to
counter terrorism and then you stop
countering terrorism you've no longer
achieved your goal here is joe biden
we went to afghanistan almost 20 years
ago
with clear goals
get those who attacked us on september
11 2001
and
make sure al qaeda could not use
afghanistan as a base from which to
attack us again
we did that
we severely degraded al-qaeda in
afghanistan
we never gave up the hunt for osama bin
laden and we got him that was a decade
ago
okay
now here's the problem
how about the fact that you just
reconstituted the possibility of al
qaeda in afghanistan according to the
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
general mark milley he informed congress
terror groups are likely to reconstitute
in afghanistan within the next two years
high probability according to dr sajan
goho of the asia pacific foundation
quoted by the bbc there are some 250 to
500 members of al-qaeda in kunar which
is a heavily forested valley region of
afghanistan right now we were able to
monitor that place and we were able to
fight with them no longer go home now
says the number is likely to increase
given the united states lack of access
to any intelligence network and its
surrender of all air bases in
afghanistan
also pakistan has now cut a quid pro quo
with the taliban to now reject us bases
on pakistani territory so we can't even
use pakistani territory to launch
attacks against the taliban or against
al qaeda
which means we are back to shooting
camels in the ass with cruise missiles
bill clinton's style from 1998.
so it's pretty likely that terrorist
groups are about to reconstitute quickly
in afghanistan and i know that we live
in the post-911 era
i know that that 911 was sort of a blip
in a lot of people's imaginations it was
20 years ago after all but let's just
remember that things that happen in
far-off countries can have some rather
radical impact in the united states just
a reminder this is why we went into
afghanistan in the first place this
right here
i know we don't play this footage very
often anymore i know we're not supposed
to because it's upsetting and
disquieting
and and shocking still 20 years later
that's the reason we went to afghanistan
because 3 000 americans were murdered on
september 11th by people the taliban
were harbouring
hey that's why we were there in the damn
first place and those same people are
just ushered back into power by joe
biden
ushered back into power with no capacity
the united states just destroyed its own
capacity to wage war on these people
that's what the united states just did
by the way the taliban you know there's
this myth out there being
being portrayed and
and perverted by the by the body
administration that the taliban is
moderated really interesting because
like two years ago the taliban chief
spokesperson was saying you know
al-qaeda wasn't even behind 911. this is
on cbs this morning from just a couple
of years ago
more stunning was shaheen's refusal to
accept al-qaeda's responsibility for the
september 11th attacks so who's the real
culprit behind so sure
that was not known who still it is not
known who was behind al-qaeda they
claimed responsibility if there is a
proof
given to us we are ready uh to try him
so
that was just two years ago the taliban
saying it was not all kind of by the way
that was the original line as well
you'll recall so now they're back in
power they're not just back in power
they now have control of billions of
dollars of us military equipment
including mine resistant ambush
protected vehicles drones humvees they
have a lot of american intel we didn't
burn our stuff before we left they have
all that stuff because joe biden decided
to pull out with no plan with no
forethought because he is a
he is a dead set idiot
i mean
either that or he's or he's perverse i
mean those are really the only two
choices and and using hanlon's razor
here i will always say somebody is
stupid rather than perverse but this is
stupidity bordering on the perverse
okay then
joe biden started to make his excuses so
his first excuse the first excuse that
he used here was that
our mission was never about
nation-building it was always about
fighting terror yes but as we've just
established you're not fighting terror
anymore that's the whole point
okay and i will say it is not entirely
joe biden's fault that there was mission
creep here right i mean there was
mission creep from the very beginning as
we'll explore here is joe biden
perverting what exactly the afghan war
was about in order to make the case for
us withdrawing even though there really
is no logical reason for us to do what
we are doing right now our mission in
afghanistan was never supposed to have
been nation-building
it was never supposed to be
creating a unified centralized democracy
our only vital national interest in
afghanistan remains today what has
always been
preventing a terrorist attack on
america's homeland
okay and then he uh you know he
continued along those lines okay so
here's the thing
he's correct originally the mission in
afghanistan had nothing to do with
humanitarian missions right here is
george w bush a long time ago now is
from october of 2001 october 11 2001
announcing that we are now at war in
afghanistan right listen to how he
describes the mission
the attack took place on american soil
but it was an attack
on the heart and soul
of the civilized world
and the world has come together to fight
a new and different war
the first and we hope the only one
of the 21st century
a war against all those who seek to
export terror
[Music]
and a war against those
governments that support or shelter them
okay now the mission creep began pretty
quickly because the united states always
has a tendency to move from real
politics to sort of wilsonian foreign
policy and immediately to move from we
need to take out the bad guys too well
what if we could also build democracy
there and historically speaking one of
the bulwarks that the united states has
used to actually solidify places has
been democracy whether you're talking
about germany what are you talking about
south korea are you talking about japan
right very often the united states does
build democracies in its wake in places
that have not been hospitable to
democracy before including nazi germany
including japan
right over the course of decades of
occupation
okay but the mission creep itself opened
the door to the counter argument which
is we shouldn't be there in the first
place remember we went there to fight
terror and then there was a bit of
mission creep and so people started
defining the mission not around fighting
terror in the minds of the american
public but instead around the mission of
fostering democracy in an inhospitable
place so listen to how george w bush in
his farewell address for example in
january of 2009 linked together these
two things right fighting al qaeda and
also at the same time fostering
democracy
afghanistan
has gone from a nation where the taliban
harbored al-qaeda
and stoned women in the streets
to a young democracy
that is fighting terror and encouraging
girls to go to school
okay now this opened the door obviously
to counter arguments which is like we
shouldn't be in afghanistan at all we
can't do a nation-building project there
which is not entirely incorrect
but here is that there was an argument
made by both barack obama and donald
trump right it was an argument that was
commonly made
we can't be there for nation building
but here is the difference between
barack obama and donald trump and joe
biden
barack obama
and donald trump both had a baseline
understanding that a precipitous pullout
from afghanistan was a foolish thing to
do
an endlessly stupid thing to do
i don't have a lot of kind words to say
about barack obama
obama knew this better than biden
because he wasn't a dumbass like a
full-scale dumbass he'll get some more
of this in just one second first let us
talk about a simple fact you need life
insurance if you're a responsible human
being you need life insurance and god
forbid you're walking down the street
and suddenly a pack of rabid hyenas
attacks you or something you need life
insurance policy genius makes it easy to
compare quotes from over a dozen top
insurers all in one place why compare we
could say 50 or more on life insurance
by comparing quotes with policy genius
you could save 1300 bucks or more per
year on life insurance by using policy
genius to compare policies the licensed
experts and policy genius work for you
not the insurance companies so you can
trust them to help you navigate every
step of the shopping and buying process
that kind of service has earned policy
genius thousands of five star reviews
across trustpilot and google and
eligible applicants can get covered in
as little as a week thanks to an
award-winning policy option that swaps
the standard medical exam requirement
for a simple phone call this exclusive
policy was recently rated number one by
forbes higher than options from ladder
ethos and bestow getting started is
simple first head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro in just minutes
you can work out how much life insurance
coverage you need you can compare
personalized quotes to find your best
price when you're ready to apply the
policy genius team handles all the rest
head on over to policygenius.com
shapiro to get started right now policy
genius when it comes to insurance it's
nice and quite important to get it right
okay so as i say
joe biden says well you know we're here
to fight terrorism except that both
barack obama who is pretty anti-war and
donald trump who's also pretty anti-war
at least understood you couldn't fully
pull out of afghanistan and remove all
the military advisors and remove all the
military support and remove everything
without collapsing the country so in may
2014 barack obama announced that we were
going to be drawing down our troops and
redefining the mission in afghanistan
pretty dramatically
but notice how he redefines the mission
he says we're going to continue to be
there right
i've made it clear
that we're open to cooperating with
afghans on two narrow missions after
training afghan forces
and supporting counter-terrorism
operations against the remnants of al
qaeda
okay right so we kept troops there right
we still had a couple thousand troops in
afghanistan
and then donald trump circa 2017. he
gave a speech about afghanistan he said
listen my initial instinct was also to
leave but then i looked at the actual
facts on the ground and i recognized
that a precipitous idiotic pullout would
end predictably and here is donald trump
saying the correct thing
my original instinct
was to pull out
the consequences of a rapid exit
are both predictable
and unacceptable
911 the worst terrorist attack
in our history
was planned and directed from
afghanistan
because that country was ruled by a
government
that gave comfort and shelter to
terrorists
a hasty withdrawal
would create a vacuum that terrorists
including isis and al qaeda
would instantly fill
just as happened
before september 11th
okay that is a difference in kind from
the moronic idiocy of joe biden who's
like let's just take out all the troops
both barack obama on the left and donald
trump on the right both of whom had
isolationist tendencies with regard to
afghanistan both of them at least
recognized you needed some base of
operations against the terrorists joe
biden it's like nope okay so then joe
biden makes another excuse he says well
you know
there are other places in the world that
have terrorists too
this is so again it boggles the mind how
foolish the man he's just a fool i mean
i keep repeating myself but it is
astonishing to realize that a man who
has been working in washington for 50
years
and was purported to be some sort of
foreign policy expert is this
empty-headed
today
the terrorist threat has metastasized
well beyond afghanistan
al-shabaab in somalia
al-qaeda in the arabian peninsula
al-nusra in syria
isis attempting to create a caliphate in
syria and iraq
and establishing affiliates in multiple
countries
in africa and
these threats
warrant our attention
and our resources
we conduct effective counterterrorism
missions against terrorist groups and
multiple countries
where we don't have permanent military
presence
okay but we do have military presence
what's our military presence in
afghanistan going to be now zero what's
it gonna be in pakistan apparently zero
we don't have one in iran so exactly
where are we going to base our
operations now by the way every country
that he mentioned we currently have
military advisors in including somalia
we've had military advisors in somalia
fighting all shabab for years
we have american bases in saudi arabia
for decades
we have american military presence in
syria
and iraq and all these other places that
he's mentioning
so what the hell's he talking about
okay then he gets to more more of the
blame game so this was the biggest
portion of his blame game he he blamed
in essence
a couple of sources one trump the other
the afghan military for what just
happened okay so he starts by blaming
trump by basically lying about the
situation on the ground in afghanistan
and the deal that trump tried to cut
with the taliban
when i came into office
i inherited a deal that president trump
negotiated with the taliban
under his agreement
u.s forces would be out of afghanistan
by may 1
just a little over three months after i
took office
u.s forces had already
drawn down during the trump
administration from roughly 15
500 american forces
to 2500 troops in country
and the taliban was at its strongest
militarily since 2001
the choice i had to make
as your president
was either to follow through on that
agreement
or be prepared to go back to fighting
the taliban
in the middle of the spring fighting
season
okay so
there's so many problems what you just
said so many lies here so many lies here
okay so let's start with this
okay when he he says that when he came
into office he'd inherited a deal that
trump negotiated with the taliban okay
so trump did have a secretary of state
mike pompeo negotiated a deal with the
taliban it was conditional the taliban
had to fulfill certain conditions before
the united states would withdraw troops
the taliban was in the process of not
fulfilling any of those conditions if
trump had been re-elected he would not
have been withdrawing the troops at this
point
everybody knows this and if he had been
withdrawing the troops he would have
been with more planning than this
okay by the way the notion that there
was this false choice between we had to
withdraw completely or we had to watch
the taliban go to war in may is nuts
that's of course not true
we would have just had the status quo
which was american forces in afghanistan
continuing to provide logistical and air
support to the afghan military status
quo would remain status quo
when he says by the way right there he
says our choice was to be prepared to go
back to fighting the taliban in the
middle of the spring fighting season
um
strange because one thing i noticed is
that winter is coming up
the afghan government explicitly asked
explicitly asked the bite administration
if you're gonna pull out delay until
winter why because afghanistan the
weather in the winter is really bad the
taliban doesn't fight in the winter
there's a fighting season in afghanistan
it is the spring in the summer
and once you hit the fall in the winter
it stops so all biden had to do was at
least wait for a few months in order to
facilitate a transfer that by the way
would have also guaranteed an ability
for people who want to get out to get
out
instead he decided to accelerate it
she's telling many many lies here
just this sunday here was former
secretary of state mike pompeo
explaining this is pathetic blame
shifting there were actual conditions to
our deal with the taliban by the way i
was against the deal with the taliban in
the first place i thought it was
foolhardy i spoke about this during the
trump administration
i think that any deal you attempt to cut
with terrorists is idiotic whether
you're talking about hezbollah or hamas
or al-qaeda or the taliban anyway even
even with that said the trump deal is
not what biden did here and by the way
since when is biden bound by deals made
by trump he's pulled out of every single
deal trump ever made
he's undermined most of the deals trump
ever like since when does he have to
respect those deals you remember that
barack obama did the same thing and
barack obama after he took over he
blamed george w bush for the status of
forces agreement in iraq and suggested
that that required him to pull out of
rock which was eminently untrue
in any case here is pompeo
i wouldn't let my 10 year old son get
away from this kind of pathetic blame
shifting
he should be less focused on trying to
blame this on someone else than to
solving the problem of making sure that
we protect and defend american security
go read the conditions that were built
into the deal i was in the room i was at
the center of working to deliver that we
negotiated a deal that performed a basis
for the conditions based withdrawal from
american soldiers i'm proud of the work
that we did there
okay so
then we get to biden shifting the blame
he starts off by blaming trump then he
moves to he's going to blame the afghan
military this is really despicable it's
really really despicable it's despicable
when you understand what he actually did
here so here is joe biden blaming the
afghans for for their own plight here
i always promise the american people
that i will be straight with you
the truth is
this did unfold more quickly than we had
anticipated
so what's happened
afghanistan political leaders gave up
and fled the country
the afghan military collapsed
sometime without
trying to fight
if anything
the developments of the past week
reinforced that ending u.s military
involvement afghanistan now
was the right decision
american troops cannot
and should not
be fighting in a war and dying in a war
that afghan forces are not willing to
fight for themselves
okay this is a slander
this is a slander when he says the
afghan forces were not willing to fight
in this war themselves 50 000 afghans
were killed over the last seven years 50
fighting the taliban
and there's a reason why the afghan
forces collapsed here
and the afghan forces collapsed here
because the united states removed all
possible logistical support
okay so let's begin at the beginning
april 14th is just a couple of months
ago here is joe biden announcing the
withdrawal
i'm now the fourth united states
president to preside over american troop
presence in afghanistan
two republicans two democrats
i will not pass this responsibility onto
a fifth
after consulting closely with our allies
and partners with our military leaders
and intelligence personnel with our
diplomats
and our development experts with the
congress and the vice president
as well as with mr ghani and many others
around the world
i've concluded that it's time to end
america's longest war
it's time for american troops to come
home
okay and then he pledged that there
would be continued american support for
for example the afghan air force okay
here is the problem as reported by the
wall street journal when he i mean
the reason the afghans turned tail and
ran is because they did not their entire
operational structure was built around
american support quote from the wall
street journal the afghan army fighting
alongside american troops was molded to
match the way the americans operate the
us military the world's most advanced
relies heavily on combining ground
operations with air power using aircraft
to resupply outposts strike targets
ferry the wounded and collect
reconnaissance and intelligence in the
wake of president biden's withdrawal
decision the u.s pulled its air support
intelligence and contractors servicing
afghans planes and helicopters
that meant the afghan military simply
could not operate anymore
in other words the force stopped
existing when the united states which
had built the entire force around u.s
support withdrew the support
according to the daily beast by the way
it goes even further than that quote the
country's mostly u.s provided air fleet
was dependent on foreign contractors to
assist with maintenance as the us
withdrawal took hold the biden
administration refused to allow
contractors into the country to service
the aircraft effectively grounding some
of the afghan air force at the same time
as the us had withdrawn director support
to afghan forces afghan officials had
hoped to draw back time at the beginning
of winter could buy them more time to
strengthen defense against the taliban
the biden administration ignored and
pushed ahead with its own timeline so
just to get this straight
we talk we didn't only remove our own
air force from the place we also
refused to allow civilian contractors
into the country to help the afghans
handle their own air force malfunction
issues
the afghans were literally on zoom calls
pointing their laptops at the
helicopters being like guys can you help
us
that's what biden did then he's like oh
yeah and then they just they dissolved i
mean they obviously didn't have the will
or alternatively you completely undercut
their ability to fight
alternatively that
and by the way
negotiated continuously with the taliban
against the advice of the afghan
government if biden started lying about
the afghan government too he was like
well you know they just wouldn't cut a
deal with the taliban what deal was
there to be cut with the taliban i'm
missing it was there a deal cut with the
taliban that looked real good over here
because i'm sort of missing that
the number of lies the number of lies
here it and by the way the biggest lie
here it really isn't an insane lie
and he says it over and over as we'll
get to in just a second
is that because the afghan military
collapsed this proves we needed to leave
okay that is sort of like arguing that
because the murder rate
rose after the police stopped policing
in america's major cities this is a
great argument for defund the police
yeah no bleep when you remove america's
support it turns out terrorists take
over
is this an argument for moving america's
support
why and how
explain
again if the idea is that you remove the
people who stand between the good guys
and the bad guys and then the bad guys
take over this is an argument for
removing the people who stand between
i'm missing the argument
why
status quo was status quo
by the way he doubled down on this too
right he said you know it's if we no
matter when we left this would have
happened
there's some very brave and capable
afghan special forces units and soldiers
but if afghanistan is unable to mount
any real resistance of the taliban now
there is no chance
that one year
one more year five more years or 20 more
years
the u.s military boots in the ground
would have made any difference
here's what i believe
to my core
it is wrong to order american troops
to step up when afghanistan's own
armed forces would not so i'm
left again to ask of those who argue
that we should stay
how many more generations of america's
daughters and sons
would you have me send to fight afghans
afghanistan's civil war
when afghan troops will not
how many more lives american lives is it
worth
how many endless rows of headstones is
arlington national cemetery
this is the most cynical nonsense it's
cynical nonsense we haven't had an
american combat casualty in afghanistan
in a year and a half
you may as well be asking how many more
american lives are we willing to risk to
have thousands of troops in south korea
or bases in germany or bases in okinawa
the hell is he talking about
he's acting as though this is 2011 in
afghanistan it is not it is 2021 in
afghanistan so he's just lying that's
just a lie
and again the idea that a little more
time wouldn't matter at all well it
certainly would have mattered in the
sense that we maybe could have helped
them restructure their military to the
point where they weren't completely
reliant on american air support
what a damned liar he is and the lies
get worse we'll get to that in a second
i mean they just kept getting worse and
worse and worse this bloviating idiot
it's more in a second first
i value a good night's sleep i need one
right now like really really badly and
that is why i cannot wait to get home
and use my pillow products as you know
my pillow has a passion to help everyone
get the best sleep of their life my
pillow didn't stop by creating the best
pillow my pillow also created the new
giza dream of bed sheets they look and
feel great that means an even better
night's sleep for me and that is crucial
for a busy schedule my pillow found the
world's best cotton it is called giza
cotton
it is ultra soft and breathable but
extremely durable my pillow sheets come
with a 60 day money back guarantee and a
10 year warranty the first night you
sleep on the giza sheets you'll never
want to sleep on anything else he's the
dream sheets come in a variety of sizes
and colors my pillow's latest incredible
deal is the sale of the year for a
limited time you'll receive 50 off the
giza dream sheets and you'll receive a
set for as low as 49.99 that is one hell
of a deal go to mypillow.com right now
click on the radio listener square use
promo code daily wire there you will
find not only this amazing offer but
also deep discounts on all my pillow
products including the my pillow
mattress topper my pillow towel sets and
so much more call
1-800-651-1148 use promo code daily wire
go to mypillow.com make sure you use
that promo code dailywire to get started
we'll get to more in a moment first let
me remind you candace owens she's she
turns on twitter like every five seconds
if you want to see her live and in
person rather than just being quote
tweeted by angry leftists i've got some
excellent news for you if you sign up
now as a daily wire member with code vip
you'll get 25 off your new membership
and you'll be automatically entered for
a chance to win a trip for two you and a
guest to the daily wire studios to see
candace live not only will you meet
candace you'll get an inside look at her
studio and front row seats to watch her
take down leftist live and at action on
her talk show candice so get a great
deal on a new dailywear membership at
dailywire.com subscribe with code vip
and 25 off and also you're gonna be
automatically entered to win a chance to
win that vip experience which is a heck
of a deal hurry the deal goes away after
wednesday you have to act fast to get
your membership discount and a chance to
win that is dailywire.com subscribe get
25 off with code vip
also some of you listening may be
sitting on the fence about joining the
daily wire if you haven't heard of
readers pass this is a great bargain for
the content for just four bucks a month
the daily wire readers pass unlocks
exclusive editorial content that unpacks
trending political and cultural topics
penned by everybody from me to people
like dan crenshaw plus analysis pieces
like the fall of andrew cuomo how an
empire built on fear came crashing down
and we have a brand new piece today out
on afghanistan it's like 4 000 words
long it is a deep dive or you can take a
deep dive with our readers past
collections those are comprised of
different articles on a given subject
current collections include the hunter
biden files and blm the organization
behind the movement when you sign up
with readers pass you also get access to
the morning wire newsletter a monday
through saturday email covering the top
stories you need to know available only
to daily one members all of this magic
can be yours for just four bucks a month
act fast right now we are offering a one
month free trial so you can really take
a look at it see if you enjoy it it's a
good deal it's also never been a better
time to take it so what exactly are you
waiting for get informed to get a
reader's pass today also if you're a fan
of the matt walsh show you've probably
heard of his sweet baby gang and if you
call yourself a part of that gang i have
excellent news the sweet baby gang is in
need of a sweet baby anthem the daily
wear is opening up for submissions the
song matt's looking for will be an
original that embodies exactly what the
sweet baby gang is all submissions
should be in the form of youtube video
links and will be judged american idol
style by matt and all of us daily
warehouse but you the viewer will be
voting on which song wins to enter go to
dailywire.com sbg for sweet baby gang
submissions end on august 25th if you
think you've got what it takes to
impress matt walsh you better get
started voting will take place on labor
day so tune in to the matt walsh youtube
channel to watch the judging of the
submissions the winner will be announced
september 8th on the matt wall show and
will wear the crown of the creator of
the most important anthem to ever be
anthemed again to enter your song into
the competition go to dailywire.com
sbg we all look forward to hearing it
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
well after joe biden finished blaming
the afghan military for its own collapse
and and blaming donald trump he then
just started saying very silly things so
this i think was the silliest thing that
he said in his entire ridiculous
submission speech here
he said that our enemies
would have been very upset if we'd
stayed in afghanistan
this is
asinine at a level beyond most
assininity it's like record levels of
ascin entity here is is joe biden i mean
i i
honestly you you lose words when when
you hear things this stupid it's as
though you're being spoken to by
an alien intelligence that does not
speak english anymore except it's really
old and has to drink cans of ensure and
it's barely sentient here's our barely
sentient president
our true strategic competitors
china and russia
would love nothing more than the united
states to continue to funnel billions of
dollars in resources and attention and
destabilizing afghanistan indefinitely
oh is that what they'd like
interesting
china and russia want us to want us to
stay so what they would really hate is
if we were to leave right that's when
that's when they would be like right now
they're quaking in their boots because
we pulled out of afghanistan and
abandoned hundreds of thousands of
people to the tender mercies of the
worst people on earth and we not only
abandon our allies and completely
undercut our allies we then celebrated
ourselves in in doing so
probably they like
nothing has made them tremble and quake
in their boots more than this unless it
was us abandoning parts of the ukraine
to to
to russia or abandoning hong kong to
china the united states over the last 20
years has become very good at abandoning
allies it's pretty impressive normally a
good foreign policy requires you to be a
good friend and a horrible enemy right
now we are a horrible friend and a
fairly good enemy
simple fact okay so here's the thing
this is so easily debunkable
but we'll do it anyway joe biden says
right there that china and russia wanted
us to stay in afghanistan
and that they would be upset with us
leaving afghanistan weird because china
immediately
seized on us leaving to say that they
will recognize the taliban and will now
work with the taliban to increase
chinese influence in the region via
their belt and road initiative
according to foreign policy magazine
china hopes to get its hands on
afghanistan's
dollar rare earth's metals they have
mountains made of rare earths over there
which is the rarest minerals
for their part the taliban are already
saying they're happy to work with the
chinese they don't give a crap that the
chinese
are imprisoning a million muslim uighurs
in zhang jiang
china's embassy and afghanistan by the
way our embassy is getting invaded
china's embassy is still open over there
so everything's going great with the
taliban with china china has also
solidified relations with pakistan
presenting a solid face against india's
the possibility of conflicts with india
has increased also just to add some
insult to injury the chinese global
times which is an official ccpcp outlet
is an official chinese communist party
out at ccp outlet
they tweeted out from what happened in
afghanistan those in taiwan should
perceive that once a war breaks out in
the straits the island's defense will
collapse in hours the u.s military won't
come to help as a result the dpp that's
the democratic people's party of taiwan
will quickly surrender
so yeah clearly they are they are you
know they're very upset that we left
clearly they're already already
threatening taiwan
and this is their goal by the way their
goal here is to threaten taiwan into
basically electing friendly government
the way that it happened in hong kong
they're hoping to do this without having
to fire a shot but if they have to fire
a shot they're really not particularly
afraid of the united states they added
quote once a cross-straits war breaks
out while the mainland seizes the island
with forces the u.s would have had to
have a much greater determination than
it had for afghanistan syria and vietnam
if it wants to interfere
it sounds an awful lot like an awful lot
like osama bin laden in the aftermath of
uss call right the united states is a
paper tiger it is a weak horse i can do
whatever i want and the us won't do
anything see betraying weakness on the
global stage is a horrible idea
by the way the chinese it's not just
completely sound and fury apparently
the people's liberation army eastern
theater command on tuesday dispatched
warships aircrafts and fighter jets for
joint live fire assault drills in the
southwest and southeast areas off the
island of taiwan as a response to recent
moves by the u.s and taiwan
secessionists
so china is already militarily
threatening taiwan in order to
presumably get them to elect some sort
of conciliatory government that will
allow taiwan to be subjected to the same
tyranny as hong kong
foreign policy horrors of acne joe biden
created a vacuum our enemies are rushing
into the vacuum see we can quit a war it
doesn't mean our enemies did guys
we can quit a war and we can walk away
and we can abandon our allies it doesn't
mean that the bad guys just go away
that's not how any of this works
i know that we've spun into our memories
the idea that abandoning vietnam was a
good foreign policy choice
it only led to the deaths of two million
people in cambodia hundreds of thousands
of people floating off the coast in
boats
that's all it led to
abandoning iran never had any bad
consequences
and this is this is all just
it's patter
for boobs who don't follow foreign
policy closely and biden knows that he
knows that
all right and he didn't stop there
because it never stops there
joe biden also decided it was necessary
to
gaslight the rest of us
i think my favorite part of this and my
favorite i mean worst is that joe biden
he gives this speech right he gets his
his big surrender speech and in his
surrender speech he then lies and says
don't worry we're still supporting the
afghan people
no i've noticed you're not that's that's
what i've noticed
call me crazy i don't think they feel
very supported right now here is biden
we will continue to support the afghan
people
we will lead with our diplomacy our
international influence and our
humanitarian aid will continue to push
for regional diplomacy and engagement to
prevent violence and instability
we'll continue to speak out for the
basic rights of the afghan people of
women and girls
just as we speak out all over the world
i've been clear
the human rights must be the center of
our foreign policy
not the periphery
but the way to do it is not through
endless military deployments
it's with our diplomacy
our economic tools
and rallying the world to join us
oh this pathetic settled sack of crap my
god
truly truly
unbelievable
don't worry guys you know we're we
haven't abandoned the people of
afghanistan i'm gonna say words
you know what the taliban takes super
seriously verbiage this is their big
thing if you send them a really pissed
off missive the taliban are like whoa
you know when you had actual air bases
here and you were dropping bombs on us
that was one thing but now that joe
biden is gonna say things
the guy who just withdrew and let us
take over he's going to say stuff and
because he says stuff we've decided
women can go to school again
we will lead with our diplomacy our
international influence and our
humanitarian aid who are going to send
the humanitarian aid to the taliban
how's that going to work exactly
our international influence with what
the 8th century cavemen
our diplomacy oh well i mean if we send
a few engraved letters via the us
embassy that no longer exists in
afghanistan
then things will probably be fine
we'll speak out for the basic rights of
the afghan people we'll speak out just
as we do all over the world you know
we'll say we'll say stuff well hashtag
bring back our girls hashtag we stand
with afghanistan
so many i mean there are so many
hashtags
the power of hashtag will emerge
victorious once again that is joe
biden's plan in afghanistan
he's been clear he says that human
rights will be the center of our foreign
policy not the periphery the basic human
right will be for the taliban to come
and just kill everyone that's that's a
pretty big human right but you know
he'll say stuff he'll say stuff when you
know between episodes of matlock he's
got a t-vote he's got like a few minutes
in between to really frame a nice tweet
or more importantly have one of his
aides frame the tweet so he can go back
to sleep and get his sleepy time in
if the lies continued
then he said you know what
we we are we are making sure that we are
evacuating everyone that's what we're
doing we're really making clear that
like our plans are in place we're a
little surprised by how fast this went
but we're evacuating everybody
our troops are working to secure the
airfield
and ensure continued operation
of both the civilian and military
flights
we're taking over air traffic control
we have safely shut down our embassy
and transferred our diplomats
our diplomatic presence
is now consolidated at the airport as
well operation allies refugee
which i announced back in july
has already moved 2 000 afghans who are
eligible for special immigration visas
and their families to the united states
amazing well a stunning number 2 000
afghans eligible for special immigration
visas and their families have moved out
that's incredible what amazing feat out
of a hundred thousand people
a hundred thousand
by the way there are still ten 000
american citizens in the country
many of them are residents journalists
or aid workers
most are trying to escape the u.s state
department sent out a tweet yesterday i
kid you not in which they said make sure
you file your paperwork properly then
they took down the tweet because they
realized how dumb that sounded
that people are going to be filing their
paperwork to get out of afghanistan as
the taliban take over and start shooting
people
according to the washington post
editorial board the state department and
defense department basically now have
two options negotiate safe passage for
american citizens with the taliban if
possible or send the us military out in
the city
to bring americans back to the airport
before the taliban gangs find them
officials working on these cases inside
the government told me they have no
clear guidance from the white house and
not enough support
also the state department is dealing
with more than 80 000 visa applications
for afghans who worked with the united
states government or find themselves at
risk by the way that is a very low
estimate that's just the number of
people who have applied in the last like
couple of weeks
if they could apply i am sure hundreds
of thousands of more people would want
to get out
in a joint statement the state
department of pentagon said well you
know our big mission is to secure the
kabul airport there yeah i love that
when biden says our troops are working
to secure the airfield you know you
might have wanted to think of that
before you pulled out all the troops you
get dope
you might want to think of it but before
you know the afghans were actually
jumping onto the wheels of planes to
escape you might have wanted to think
about all of that that might have been a
thing worth thinking about
the statement said quote tomorrow and
over the coming days you will be
transferring out of the country
thousands of american citizens who have
been resident in afghanistan
as well as thousands of afghans who are
in danger
but even the mission to secure the
airport is going awry says the
washington post on monday u.s troops
shot dead at least two armed men who are
among the masses storming the airport as
monday afternoon u.s officials said the
flights to and from the airport had
stalled
there was one u.s military plane where
the the
people who were staffing the plane
so many afghans climbed onto like
hundreds of extra afghans trying to
escape climbing on the plane and you
want to talk about actual empathy the
pilots of the plane the staff of the
plane the american military talk about
brave people they said okay we're over
capacity we're taking off anyway they
saved 640 people on that plane
that is what american soldiers do
american cowards act like like president
biden acts
american that this was i think the most
stunning thing on tv yesterday in terms
of the commentary there's an american
veteran his name is matt zeller he was
on msnbc with former four-star general
brian williams
who who still has a you know when he's
not dodging sniper fire in in iraq uh he
was on with uh with matt teller and
brian williams came on after the biden
speech and talked about how wonderful
biden was and then matt zeller proceeded
to just crap all over him
i feel like i watched a different speech
than the rest of you guys i was appalled
there was such a profound bold faith lie
in that speech the idea that we plan for
every contingency i have been personally
trying to tell this administration since
it took office i've been trying to tell
our government for years that this was
coming we sent them plan after plan on
how to evacuate these people nobody
listened to us they didn't plan for the
evacuation of our afghan wartime allies
they're trying to conduct it now at the
11th hour the thing that they were most
concerned about was with the optics of a
chaotic evacuation well they got exactly
what they were most concerned of by
failing to do what was right when we
could have done it
correct
this is correct
and but buttons didn't stop there
i mean it just it was just a con it was
just a fire hose of lies
where's the fact check where's daniel
dale on cnn to debunk all the lies i
thought facts matter facts first
well here's joe biden continuing to lie
he says well you know some people might
be wondering why we didn't start
evacuating people sooner
it's everybody else's fault
oh
you you thought it was his fault no no
no no no it's ever it's your fault
probably it's everybody's fault
aren't we all at fault in the end aren't
we all just sinners before in the hands
of an angry god here is joe biden
i know there are concerns about why we
did not begin evacuating
afghans civilians sooner
part of the answer
is some of the afghans did not want to
leave earlier
still hopeful
for their country
and part of it because the afghan
government
and its supporters discouraged us from
organizing the mass exodus to avoid
triggering as they said
a crisis of confidence
okay so um
a question he says you know the afghan
government and its supporters they told
us not to organize the mass exodus
because it would trigger a crisis of
confidence
that is that what happened is that
really interesting so you were saying
let's get everybody out and the afghan
government was like please don't do that
because it'll undermine the possibility
of us fighting back and so joe biden was
like okay or alternatively joe biden was
saying last month none of this would
happen flashback joe biden last month
you wonder why people didn't flee
because the president of the united
states said last month no one needed to
flee everything was fine all is well
do you see any parallels between this
withdrawal and what happened in vietnam
with some people feeling whatsoever
zero what you had is you had entire
brigades breaking through the gates of
our embassy
six if i'm not mistaken
the taliban is not the south of the
north vietnamese army
they're not they're not remotely
comparable in terms of capability
there's going to be no circumstance
where you see people being lifted off
the roof of a
embassy in the of the united states from
afghanistan it is not at all comfortable
so maybe people didn't flee because the
president of the united states was lying
to them a month ago
okay and then the lies just continued he
said well you know what if the taliban
start attacking people we'll do
something about that won't we we'll ah
really we're gonna bloviate yes because
well i'm not afraid to use force as the
man who just pulled out 2 500 troops for
no reason and then has to send in 7 000
troops to secure the surrender of the 25
2500 troops who are leaving
here's the president
as we carry out this departure
we have made it clear to the taliban
if they attack our personnel
or disrupt our operation
the u.s presence will be swift and the
response will be swift and
forceful
we will defend our people with
devastating force if necessary
our current military mission
we shortened time
limited
scope
and focused in its objectives
get our people and our allies safely as
quickly as possible
oh yeah i'm sure he he's so credible
okay then biden after blaming every
other human being on earth you blame the
afghan military you blame trump he
blames everybody it's everybody's fault
except for this guy then he says the
buck stops with me
oh yes i believe you sir i sure sure
i am president of the united states of
america
and the buck stops with me
i'm deeply saddened by the facts we now
face
but i do not regret my decision to end
america's war fighting in afghanistan
and maintain
a laser focus on our counter-terrorism
missions there and other parts of the
world i cannot and will not ask our
troops to fight
on endlessly another in another
country's civil war
taking casualties
suffering life-shattering injuries
leaving families broken by grief and
loss
this is not in our national security
interest
it is not what the american people want
it is not
what our troops who have sacrificed so
much over the past two decades deserve
okay our troops by the way
i hope you've talked to somebody who
served in afghanistan there is no one
more devastated today by what joe biden
has done than the people who served in
afghanistan
who spent their lives who left their
limbs in afghanistan
in order to preserve america against
terrorists taking over that place
this ass just pulled everybody out to
let the taliban take over in the name
of those soldiers
yeah i think not
i think not if the buck stops with joe
biden then it stops at the joe biden
the thousands of corpses in the streets
those will be on joe biden the women
will get hit with acid in the face that
is on joe biden
the rebuilding of terror groups in
afghanistan will be on joe biden
the movement by china into the region
will be on joe biden chinese more
aggressive movement in the south china
sea and against taiwan will be on joe
biden russia's more aggressive movement
with regard to the middle east syria
iran that will be on joe biden iran and
hezbollah moving on israel that will be
on joe biden when you create a vacuum in
american foreign policy someone else
takes over it will all be on joe biden
the buck indeed stops with him and so do
the corpses they stop at his door
because he created this he owns it and
even though he tried to blame everybody
else on earth he is the one who owns it
in the end he has created the saigon
it's amazing he spent a month trying to
claim saigon wouldn't happen and then
saigon happened and now he's bragging
about it he concluded his speech by
bragging that this was just like saigon
remember a month ago saigon was a
disaster this would never be like saigon
never now it's exactly like saigon and
he's happy about it
i made a commitment to the brave men and
women who served this nation that i
wasn't going to ask them to continue to
risk their lives in a military action
that should have ended long ago
our leaders did that in vietnam when i
got here as a young man
i will not do it in afghanistan
okay so there he is right he says the
the ending of the war in vietnam was
supposed to end it was supposed to end
right what happened in saigon the
democratic congress defunded the south
vietnamese government it took four and a
half months after that defunding against
the advice of gerald ford for the
vietcong to overrun saigon
and for us to have to evacuate our
embassy and for hundreds of thousands of
people to float off the coast in boats
and for two million people to be killed
in cambodia joe biden thinks that was
good in the end after all of this after
all of this after he said this wasn't
going to be like saigon it wasn't going
to be like vietnam doesn't mean like any
of that he says you know what it is like
that and it's good that it's like that
because vietnam for so many people like
joe biden the vietnam syndrome
is not something to be avoided it is
something to be championed
a weak america on the foreign policy
stage is good
joe biden does not see america's
interests as interest to be pursued by a
variety of ends ranging from the
diplomatic to the military and sometimes
in tandem instead
he sees diplomacy as the end in and of
itself
military force is always bad
and i'm seeing a lot of people on the
right today saying things like well you
know now that we're bringing these
military we're not spending 40 million
and 40 billion bucks in afghanistan
every year and we're not having the
american military in afghanistan this
will allow us to redeploy show of hands
who thinks we're going to redeploy to
the southern border
anybody
show of hands who thinks that we're
going to up our naval forces in the
south china sea with the resources we
just saved in afghanistan or confront
the russians or confront the iranians
now who thinks that what joe biden just
did is going to be the predicate for a
series
of regional surrenders around the globe
to other
heterogeneous powers who are interested
in seizing power against the interests
of the united states
this is the same administration that is
busily working to surrender to china
busily working to grant power to russia
by greenlighting the nordstrom 2
pipeline this is the same administration
that is attempting to currently
negotiate a deal with the molocracy in
iran
this is not a this is not a bug in the
system joe biden is happy about it
he does not look at what's happening in
afghanistan as an unfolding incipient
disaster
it was his goal it's what he wanted he
bragged about it yesterday and by the
way he then took like two questions
turned around left the room went back on
vacation
that's how much empathetic grandpa cares
that's how much he cares
because he thinks this is a victory for
him and their members of the press are
already championing it you're already
starting to see editorial boards from
the left going oh well you know it is
heroic after all i mean that speech i
mean that really was an amazing speech
and if people are on the right fall for
this crap seriously if they fall for the
idea that this was somehow good for the
united states
i don't know what to tell you
the world has a habit of clocking
american isolationist tendencies
in the aftermath like
one of the things that joe biden said
here and he continues to say it
is that the united states basically has
no interest in the in the outcome
of wars in other countries well we kind
of do when it turns out that they have
an impact on us
it's happened many many times in
american history where sort of
non-interventionist policy ends up
bearing some pretty rotten fruit
ranging all the way back to america's
non-intervention in the russian civil
war
of 1917 1918
where we basically just stood aside let
the communists take over with like a
skeleton for us that only led to 70
years of cold war
or where the united states did not
actually leave any sort of troops in
europe in the aftermath of world war one
leading to the rise and reconstitution
of the nazi power
see the thing is this when it comes to
foreign policy foreign policy is very
often
about the risk that you take to to to
stop things that have not yet
materialized and so it's very easy for
people who are isolationists to say well
nothing's materialized it would have
been that way anyway it's very easy to
say okay you know 20 years in
afghanistan what did we get for our
money what did we get for it and the
answer typically from people on the
right has been what we got is no 911.
that was the cost right the cost was no
911s no global al-qaeda power that was
the cost
right that's what we got
that was what we bought
with all that blood and treasure that's
what we got and people on the
isolationist right and on the far left
they will say things like well you know
maybe that wasn't going to happen anyway
maybe it was over already how do you
know
well there's no way to prove a negative
right we can't we can't say for sure
that if the united states had never done
anything in afghanistan that their that
terror attacks wouldn't have stopped
maybe they would have stopped who knows
who knows but there is one thing that is
certain when the united states removes
itself from the world's sphere the world
becomes more dangerous for the united
states not less the world is not kind to
people who cower behind their own
borders the world is not kind to people
who sit and do nothing on the global
stage
particularly world powers the world is
not kind to those people
because you can either
you can either fight the battles when
they are far away and when they require
a minimum of blood and toil as they do
now right not at the beginning of the
afghan war now and we are talking about
44 billion dollars a year and zero
american lives lost per year or you can
wait until global powers have decided
that they see a vacuum and they move and
the wars become ever more costly
that is the lesson of the 20th century
it seems as though we're going to have
to relearn it in the 21st alrighty we'll
be back here today
with another hour of content coming up
soon the matt wall show airs at 1 30 pm
eastern be sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show